Washington DC is finally in a state
where it's somewhat stable now it's time
to get on the offensive after securing
the perfusion bioreactor from the
dadlabs the next step is to start mass
producing the antivirals but in order to
do this the right people are required to
run the project so that it can be safely
distributed among the population the
Taylor Chernenko is one of the very few
surviving expert virologists who also
had first-hand experience working with
the creator of the original dollar flute
dr. Gordon Amherst his skill set would
be invaluable for this task and it just
so happens that after all these months
that the shd has managed to locate him
for the last eight months or so Vitelli
has been a hostage of aaron keener
however it now seems that the black tusk
have managed to get their hands on him
they are keeping him on Coney Island in
a holding cell in the middle of a local
ball park but how did they get hold of
him kina surely wouldn't have just
handed him over his kenan out teamed up
with the black tusk and what the hell
the cleaners doing there
[Music]
you
since relatively early on in the
outbreak Vitelli has been a prisoner of
Aaron kena
while working with the LMB kena captured
him from the Russian consulate before
the division was able to step in when
the sht pursued the LMB to the
headquarters rather than stay and fight
kena left them for dead
taking Vitali with him up until now this
was the last we heard of the tele
training Co kena hurt openly told the
shd that along with Gordon Amherst
research notes and a DNA printer he
would be powerful version of the virus
many months later they both seem to have
come out of hiding but he will use this
on himself this is all just an elaborate
way to get me to killing the magic
fashion I don't know how anyone could
live with themselves after the things he
has done
I don't know how to live with myself I
didn't know what I was doing when I was
working with honest that work was about
science not the application I didn't see
the applications but now with Keener's
virus I see too many and all of them
terrify me
I'm sorry mr. Kenneth I don't know what
happened it's okay we can try again I
don't have anymore of the viral samples
they were destroyed in the experiment
that's fine you don't keep all your eggs
in one basket
I get more you have the virus course
Vitaly I get whatever you need just stay
focused on your work and try to stay
calm
you make silly mistakes when you're
stressed I wouldn't want you to hurt
yourself
Thank You mr. Kiner sleep well I'll get
you another sample I'll see you in the
morning
truth was would Keener's been using the
telly to create and perfect his new and
improved version of the virus the telly
has obviously been trying his best not
to help and in fact sabotage the project
Makena being kina was prepared for this
time from exposure determination has
been cut in half
average time of death after exposure on
the last batch was 5 minutes and 24
seconds I wanted to be I wanted to help
people to cure cancer with viruses not
to weaponize them but keener he forces
me to use my research too I wish I was
brave enough to take my own life but yet
I'm a coward it would be so easy to just
drop a vial on the ground and let it
take me but I can't if I get it down to
one minute then then I think I wouldn't
be afraid anymore I could handle that
pain for a minute but not for 5
okay back to work the telly has been
well looked after by kena but he's still
pushing him to do something that is
completely against his morals keener is
a dangerous man and vitelli is well
aware of what he's capable of
although he's been good to him as far as
one could be when held captive Vitali is
worried about what might happen to him
if he doesn't do what is instructed he
is alone and he's been a hostage for so
long that he has no idea if anyone is
even looking for him or even knows that
he's missing in Vitelli eyes it feels
strong enough he would have removed
himself from the equation long ago the
sort of work isn't he wanted to help
people
no of course not we'll keep you safe
you really done exceptional work and
people are starting to take notice black
tusk professional if each leaf Italian
completed kinas tusk he had created a
new witnessed version of the virus that
was capable of killing Sam who was
exposed in just over five minutes so
Keenan now has a new plan for him he was
gifting them to the black tusk but what
was it getting in return for him kina is
well aware of the value of having such
an asset so the black tusk must have
something that he really needs
so what's the deal here you're just
gonna give us to Nick oh yes what do you
want in return I got something in mind
don't worry it's a reasonable trade I'll
send you the details from what I've
heard about you you don't strike me as
reasonable you can't believe everything
you hear
Delores Jones we're not on a first-name
basis
you're not my friend kena you're a tough
cookie
Jones respect Delores Jones is the black
tusk commander in New York she occupies
the Coney Island area in Brooklyn kina
contacted Jones and offered Battaglia's
a trade she's likely the one that we saw
in the trailer leading up to episode 3
naturally knowing keener and his past
Jones was suspicious and questions kinas
motives he simply stated that he has
something in mind for a future date who
suddenly pushed her suspicions further
but the Russian scientist was too
valuable to pass up this offer I expect
him to have a virus clean but if you're
worried about it
just put him in quarantine you really
ain't making it easier to trust you I'm
sure you've got resources at your
disposal stick him in a box and have
your medics kill more once over we'll
see just healthy as anyone can be
worried that Vitali might be infected
with the green poison he was placed in
the containment chamber so he could be
monitored before moving him on she had
brought in BTS you operative Elijah
Sumner to help her team protect the
asset and this is when it became
apparent that the shd were aware of what
was happening on the island
Vivian Connelly is a former division
agent who turned her back on the sh t
not long after she lost her family to
the green poison earlier on in the
outbreak before activation she was a
counterterrorism intelligence agent and
chemical engineer after parting ways
with the division she came across the
now leaderless members of the clean
affection they took her in understanding
the pain and suffering she was going
through Conley went on to reassemble the
cleaners and reignite their purpose of
eradicating the virus and all of those
responsible for its creation she picked
up with Joe Farah liftoff before he was
slain by the agents at the SH D except
this time they'll being led by Sauron
with a military background
someone who's highly trained in strategy
and has in-depth knowledge and insight
into the enemy they were coming up
against Conley set forth upgrading their
weapons and equipment and helped place
this grief-stricken group of ex
government contract workers into a far
more driven and formidable force in the
city has ever seen before cleaners don't
trust outsiders I trust you
I'm not an outsider I just want to help
don't wanna know where their Intel is
coming from and you're an agent I know
how resourceful you can be and if they
keep pushing just tell me what's good
Zika okay
why can you get it to me tomorrow just
tell me where and when to meet you
you know where I stand keener I do
Vivian this is important to you we need
to get justice for your family you know
where yes I do
you're positive last man battalion had
him black tusk showed up and they were
more than happy to switch sides
Chernenko has been in their custody the
whole time that Russian [ __ ]
it's gonna pay for what she did you have
to be smart about it
I'll appear on the boardwalk then your
team will declare a strike all right
won't know what hit him fast forward to
the events happening on Coney Island
condley is approached by Erin keener he
informs her up to tell his whereabouts
and that the LMB has headed the whole
time without their leader they joined up
with the black tusk and were absorbed
into their ranks on top of this they
handed over custody of the Russian
scientists consumed by rage and thrilled
by the idea of being able to enact
revenge on someone that they deemed
responsible for helping cause the doll
flu outbreak Conley ordered the cleaners
to assault the black tusk on Coney
Island the cleaners couldn't know that
Kong was getting this information from
Erin Tina firstly as calmly said they
don't trust outsiders and secondly if we
remember from the Westside piers in the
division one all of the factions were
hunting kina down so it's horrendously
unlikely that they would trust any Intel
coming from them and they will be right
we can see from these interactions that
Kino isn't just betraying the black tusk
by sending in the cleaners to have their
revenge but he's also manipulating a
fellow rogue agent in order to have a
carry out his plans
the taillight rudenko doesn't know it
but is the most valuable asset on the
planet right now
the shd need them to oversee the
management and production of the
antivirals that had to be dispersed
among the population the black tusk
wanted for presumably the same thing
when they managed to recapture the
bioreactor in antivirals from the White
House in the cleanest well they just
want to see them burnt however
unfortunately for the cleaners the
division beat them to it they launched a
strike on the island having to throw all
caution to the wind in order to extract
Vitelli they had to strike hard and fast
before the black task had time to react
the division managed to extract vitally
before an unexpected attack from the
cleaners swept across the island the
division agents fall back as the
cleaners quickly began to burn through
the remaining forces of the black tusk
Dolores Jones in the black tusk quickly
catch on that they've been portrayed by
Kino the shd find out that Kino is still
close and proceeded to search for him on
the island while the cleaners are
burning everything is site and the bulk
of the black task force has been kept
busy the division agents manage to come
across and killed both Elijah Sumner and
Dolores Jones effectively putting an end
to the black tusk presence on Coney
Island
I lost control of the drone who the hell
is doing this
[Music]
congratulations agent you've got
tremendous okay you can keep him is
served his purpose now this operation
went much smoother than I expected and
that is partially thanks to you
I know it's frustrating I'm right here
and you're right there but never forget
I will always be one step ahead of you
I'm in control because I'm not afraid to
take control you still follow orders
that's why you'll never win
while scouting the island with a drone
to locate kina control of the drone was
suddenly lost although it seems he
wasn't expecting the division to be
involved in this conflict he certainly
doesn't appear to be faced by their
involvement the division of once again
mr. opportunity to capture kina but the
puzzling thing is kina says this
operation went much smoother than
expected partially due to you so what
did he actually achieve obviously he
managed to wipe out the black dust in
the area but that surely couldn't have
been all yes vitally finished making his
new super virus so didn't matter if he
was used as bait to bring the cleaners
up against the black tusk but over
feeling that it certainly wasn't in his
plan for the shd to rescuer so for the
first time they may have actually
managed to get one up on him
but regardless he got away and he's now
equipped with a new far more deadly
version of the virus he also happens to
have the entire clean affection under
his control and directly at least plus
as we've seen from the wallets of New
York trailers here's the Rikers faction
as well so for me with his army growing
and now the new virus the risks he took
on Coney Island just to remove the black
tusk presence doesn't make complete
sense to me I'm sure there's more to the
story that I'm sure we'll hear about in
year two war loads of New York
so in summary Tina had Vitali create a
new more dangerous version of the virus
kina then gifted Vitali to the black
tusk and turned for some help in the
future
KYNA manipulated fellow rogue agent
Vivian Connelly now a highly influential
member of the cleanest into attacking
the black tusk the shd launched an
attack on Coney Island and rescue
patellae the black tusk on Coney Island
were wiped out by the division in the
cleaners Aaron Keenan managed to escape
and is happy with how the operation went
we already know from the year two
trailers that will be following kina
into lower Manhattan but what do you
think Kino is up to what's been going on
on Coney Island they've changed Kino a
little with the SIP suit and the
upcoming expansion don't get me wrong
he's still totally my boo he just seems
a lot more evil all of a sudden more of
a classic villainous character than
we've seen in the past anyway hopefully
this cleared up the story little as to
what's happened in episode 3 if you were
at all interested in the lore of the
game and you're needing a little bit of
a recap I have a ton of videos in the
description dating all the way back to
when the virus was first released in the
division 1 I warn you though some of
those earlier videos are a little
crunchy I've learned a lot in the last
couple years around production value I
think thank you very much for watching
please let me know if anything needs
clarifying and I'll catch you in the
next one Cheers
[Music]